[Music]
a long time ago when i did the movie
dodgeball i was having to do my what
they call epk it stands for electronic
press kit it's basically when you do the
interview about the making of the movie
so one day we were all uh very excited
because it was the day that david
hasselhoff was going to do his cameo in
the movie and
he did it was very funny he was
ad-libbing he was making
self-referential jokes about how he's
big in germany which he is huge huge
and it was very funny because he was
very like self-deprecating and funny and
um and then uh and i was waiting to do
my epk
and they said you know another actor is
doing it now so it's gonna be a little
while and i looked and i noticed that it
was david hasselhoff who was doing it
and
i'm not exaggerating i think it took him
about 10 minutes to shoot his part in
the movie maybe 15
and his epk
went on for at least an hour of of him
talking about his experience
shooting those 15 minutes what can you
do you just have to wait for him it's
he's the off you can't hassle the ha ha
you say you're just
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is
my uh co-host
i was going to try to find a david he's
showing me his teeth i was once uh in oh
yeah david hasselhoff too oh you don't
both have to be in movies with david
house off
that's right i totally forgot yeah i'm
i've been uh like obsessed with david
hasselhoff for so many years wow yeah
you get it you're flush oh my god he
uh we used to watch that that uh he did
that broadway play he did jekyll and
hyde on broadway and they and they
filmed it yeah oh this is i wonder if
it's on youtube the funniest part of it
is the is this what you're going to say
yeah the curtain call so when he comes
out to do his bow
if you haven't seen this i'm sure it's
on youtube it's the most epic just this
like
grandiose sweeping
and then what does this give a speech oh
yeah afterwards he was like did you like
the show did you like the show
it was amazing i forgot about that he's
like the most ego maniacal human being
who's ever lived maybe he's up there
with like genghis khan you know
so when i did but he's much better for
the world but he's nice i when i met him
he was he couldn't have been nicer
that's a funny combination of like
michael but really nice yeah complete
narcissist but really sweet
i did a little part in this movie called
hop
and again david hezlofth had a cameo and
i was in a scene with him and he we were
in the makeup trailer together and he
he had brought to set all these little
pieces of memorabilia hasselhoff like
don't hassle the hoth memorabilia like
pins and shirts i think you told me this
oh really and he had and he had kind of
spread it out
throughout the set like he had put it
like you know
near where they were shooting he put it
all over the makeup he put it he gave it
to everybody like in their own trailer
it's actually kind of you're right
really nice it's that's funny that's a
perfect example of that combination
narcissistic and really nice it was half
this half that all these like things
and he was talking about his kids i was
sitting next to him in the makeup
trailer and he said yeah my um
so she was my youngest was uh doing this
or that and i said oh how many um how
many kids do you have
and he looked at me kind of with this
incredible incredulous face and he said
offspring
oh that's like dead seriously i said oh
yeah sorry how many
offspring do you have
he's a fascinating human being
i forgot that story oh my god that's so
much better than
my story that we started we started well
and you also worked with russell brand
in that right yes hop is about this
little you all know oh yeah it's about
this little cartoon bunny in the movie
he ends up becoming uh a contestant on
this america's got talent kind of
reality show spoiler alert and i think
was a judge if i recall oh and one in my
scene was i had to bring
the bunny who was obviously uh not there
maybe he was like a tennis ball he was a
tennis ball and i had to bring him as
the production assistant for this fake
show i had to bring him into
the audition where david hasselhoff was
judging him and russell brand played
the other production assistant it was a
little wink he's also in the movie he's
playing the voice of the bunny oh that's
fine anyway who gives a [ __ ] i may have
gotten cut out even i've never seen it
but i get residuals all the time why
have you never seen it that's weird i
don't like watching myself or listening
to myself
yeah you don't like listening to me or
living with myself
okay well i'll say that for another
episode
that's one of the first times i realized
that uh in different parts of the world
they have such different relationships
with certain celebrity like
when he when the when the berlin wall
came down which was arguably one of the
biggest historical events in our
lifetime
he played i mean he like
he he played there he was that big he
was that a massive star i think he might
i don't know if he still is but at one
point he was like the biggest star in
germany yeah and and very entertaining
and by the way even in like jekyll and
hyde he's really good in it he's good i
think he's talented he's good at
baywatch he's good in knight rider yeah
i think he's a fine performer but what's
fascinating about him is his personality
personality is great yeah well so that
epk that we did that was like i mean god
knows what he was talking about for an
hour and and he they left in some of his
self-referential comments in dodgeball i
think it's in the movie still if it's
not in the deleted scenes like he does
well it was written in he does that
thing in german he's the head coach the
german team and he was totally game to
do it you know like it'd be great to get
him as a guest oh my god but right now
why are we talking about him well yeah
as you mentioned he starred in the show
baywatch and later they remade that
movie they the show into a movie
whatever you mean yeah okay
uh and today we're gonna be talking to
one of the stars of that movie
alexandra de dario
dario
a fun name to say it really is alex
tadario and uh alex and i are friends uh
we met each other about it
a year and a half ago two years ago
through a mutual friend john bass
hopefully he's listening
and uh let's get right into it we talk
about john what else do we need if
you're not familiar with bill watch
she's who's not familiar with baywatch
well i know but the movie version of it
uh yeah she's also in uh she's in like
huge
huge blockbuster movies yeah just look
her up well
the rock she's
another one san andreas yes i'm sure
you've seen it about it's one of the
most famous fault movies um what else oh
true detective of course and uh anyway
she yeah she's in a ton of stuff and uh
she's in a great movie now that i just
saw called uh
we are we summon the darkness i was
about to say what we do in the shadows
yes we talk about we summon the darkness
and uh baywatch and what else well
you'll hear it yeah yeah okay here it is
uh my ketchup with my pal alexandra
d'addario
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
i literally just came from watching
uh we summon the darkness oh you did
you're very good and the movie's great
uh
it's it's it has
and it also makes sense i was thinking
in the context of like having sent you
that neil debut script it totally makes
sense why you wouldn't want to do that
movie
um
talk about it now
well no no no we shouldn't talk about it
but like i mean whatever it's it's uh
there's so many similarities it just
felt so yeah there are i mean i like
what the director i love i love that
writer i did another film that he wrote
and it's this i think people get
confused about whether it's a horror or
comedy and that's where some but it's
like it's supposed to be funny and scary
but humor was our main thing and i think
everyone really leaned into the
performances
to make it a little bit extra over the
top and that's why it's so fun
yeah that must have been fun to and it
and it it also plays on your
appearance like you have
i'm sure you've heard this before i'm
sure reviews have said this that your
eyes your face can go from
it has like an ethereal beauty but it it
if that's
oh my god if that's turned at all if
that come if whatever that face is doing
becomes sinister then your face becomes
like really sinister thank you so much
no i like that though and that was what
was fun about
doing that and it's like i play and i
think people think of me as like this
you know
pretty
maybe even i don't well i don't really
know but i i like
really leaning into when i open my eyes
really wide i look really creepy yeah
and like you know yeah well you almost
said pretty it's hard to you can't say
that people think of you as being pretty
but i can say people think of you as
being pretty you're pretty
sorry
cat's out of the bag
well you gotta watch me swim in the
darkness and then you you know well
that's true but that's that's what one
of the great things about it it's it
plays with a lot of conventions and um
it's so good it's on netflix now i
really recommend it and it triggers guys
it's a fun time it's really fun it
reminded me of um
i made a movie called tusk that is
really uh
similar like you know people being uh
well certainly being drugged i also had
an experience in my life uh years ago
that
the reason i can't re-watch tusk and the
reason why it's difficult for me to
watch we sum in the darkness is because
it really triggers um
something that i went through it's just
being drugged uh i don't know if you've
ever had that experience i hope you
haven't i have not been drugged
um you told me this story yeah
you told me this story the first time i
met you
oh boy it was a riveting
a riveting story i mean
but not one that should be told the
first time you're meeting somebody have
you told this story publicly like on
your podcast yeah about this story yeah
context
it's a wild story yeah but it's i just
watching your movie everyone plays it's
played so real and uh right and that
turn oh my and this if you haven't seen
the movie pause right now
i'm gonna give some seconds okay the
turn where you drug
where you drug the guys uh and they're
beginning to realize that my
my blood started pumping more during
that moment because it's that moment of
realization where
you you know you're about to lose
control and you know you're now at the
mercy of somebody else that is so
[ __ ] scary i mean regardless if
you've had that direct experience or not
but it's played so well in the movie um
it's really scary i think that the
thought of being out of control is
terrifying for anybody yeah and so
that
moment
and you having experienced it just that
moment of oh [ __ ]
i'm completely out of control of what
happens to me right now oh
it's off on those guys the actress the
acting is so good in addition to your
performance though oh everyone did such
a great job i was so
everyone did such a great job i also had
a moment last night where i was reminded
of you because i was watching the jerk
and
yeah
which i only recently discovered i'm
embarrassed to say but i
when i did i and i've people have
recommended it over the years my friends
people like
that you only recently discovered it a
year ago i know this is so this was my
second time watching it and i
i was thinking of you and i thought i
couldn't put my finger on why
um and it hit me that you did a great
rendition of
that ukulele song that they sing in the
movie
you belong to me
yeah i mean that's a beautiful song it's
a beautiful song and then i looked for
it and do you have a recording of it
because i couldn't find it's deep deep
on my instagram i think okay so people
it wasn't like a recording of it i think
i just did it with with one of the crew
members on set of
um
the movie i did right after
we summoned so it was probably around
the time yeah so you loved movies like
that growing up did you discover those
when you were a kid
yeah my mom introduced me to a few
movies um
like i think the movies we had on repeat
were disney movies ghostbusters
um
the jerk she introduced me to
um
one brother one sister i have a brother
and a sister and we would all watch
these movies i mean my sister's a little
bit younger she's seven years younger
than me so i think it was a little bit
different but i have always been a huge
fan and i think i gravitated towards
sort of the absurd
um
and um i've just been a big fan of the
absurd and absurd comedy and um
like python i love monty python but i
find life to be very absurd i think that
i don't think it should be taken that
seriously and i like movies that reflect
that and i like things that are like i
like grand romantic films like moulin
rouge and
things that are or like american beauty
too is one of my favorite movies and i
remember seeing that when i was what 13
or something and just being like what
the hell is what is this
um because it's such an elevated emote
like it's so over the top so heightened
but that feels truer to life than me i
think a lot of life is us pretending
everything is normal well that's funny
you said that i was uh our last guest
was carrie brownstein we were talking
about portlandia and um
i
i think my love of portlandia comes from
uh
comes from that analyzing the absurd in
in
our you know human interactions and and
nobody does that better than portlandian
she made a point that we were talking
specifically about fred armisen does the
sketch where it's his one have you seen
his one-man show
sketch
um it's just fred doing a one-man show
look you'll love it on youtube and
carrie's in the audience she's the only
person in the audience and she
it's like
and we were talking about why fred is so
good why the show is so good and
she made the point which you just did
about we sum in the darkness which is it
all depends on
uh the lens through which you watch
something so if you tell people uh that
that one-man show he does is not that
different than a lot of one-man shows
i've seen the difference is you're
watching a comedy you're watching it
through the lens of a comedy and um and
so the whole thing becomes absurd and
funny but but if you went to that guy's
one-man show and knew that it was
serious uh
it would be difficult to laugh at it
would only be funny like in a
uh
like irreverent way you wouldn't really
be able to laugh out loud at it um
but i think it all depends on
how you see it through the lens the lens
through which you see it um so we summon
the darkness if you tell me it's a
comedy i so far it's they're funny
elements but like
there's also something
really unsettling
yeah it's a horror comedy so i think but
i think you're right expectations
feed so much of all kinds of stuff in
life and expectations from what we
expect from a person from a whatever and
i think that
because you can create a whole i and i
think it's true with movies like if
you've been told i mean this happens a
lot if you've been told a movie is
amazing by everybody
and then you go in and it's like you're
expecting i don't know what you're
expecting but then you know even if it's
good it's you've built it up in your
mind just raises the bar unnecessarily
and we summon is
such a well done horror comedy in my
opinion and um i think reviewers who got
it but i think that if you go in
thinking it's just a straight horror
you'll miss the comedic elements of it
yeah that's true i'm actually glad i
went in knowing
nothing about it because yeah it starts
off it it really subverts your
expectations and so i i hate even
after having talked about it i hate
talking about it and giving people
certain expectations but um
yeah just see it just see it it's right
have you had that experience on a movie
where you felt it was going it ended up
being something completely different
um
either in a disappointing way or in a
good way
it's not that i expect that i it's
turned out to be something completely
different
it's usually sometimes you'll be on a
film and i'm sure you've had this
experience and
you know you don't when you go into a
film you're putting your trust into the
director the other actors that you're
putting your trust that
um
that they have a very clear vision so
the biggest thing i've seen that happens
is that you can sort of figure out
pretty quickly that the director
sometimes doesn't actually have a clear
vision so it's not that
they know the tone but that
you're just like i don't know that this
movie's going the right like it's not i
don't know
that's always scary when it's yeah when
you hear something
oh sure sure it's hard and hard yeah
yeah when you say when you have a
specific question and you get the like
i don't know um try it both ways and
it's like those are two very different
ways like that's a little unsettling
yeah or
on one film it was like let's shoot it
with both eye lines because we can't
figure out which eye lines that's
happened to me before and i'm like
you're telling me we have to shoot the
performance with me looking both to the
right of camera and the left camera
because we don't know
the eye that sucks because then you
start thinking like
isn't that just like technical stuff
that that's your job to know like i'm
not gonna say like i'm not gonna do a
take where i'm like i'm gonna be both uh
happy and really miserable during this
take um yeah that's it's my job to like
make a choice to like know
uh yeah that's unsettling that's scary
well i mean look i mean there's more
unsettling things but sometimes there's
little signs that that there's
too much confusion and then yeah and
there's a lot of times i've been on a
project and you just have and you know
the director's really confident and
really has a clear vision and you you
can totally write and you feel so safe
in
riding with that and and following
because i
i like to get lost in
you know when i'm working and i don't
like to
think about what i like to just do what
i like to do
you know um
so i like it when the director has a
very clear idea do it this way do it
this way do it this way do it this is me
too i like following
i like following orders i like
putting myself in putting my faith in
somebody yeah um
what was was bill i've never asked you
about this and it's a movie i've seen a
lot bill macy what was william h macy
like as a director
i loved him he directed you in the
layover i just love him
yeah i mean i
i i did that movie
i thought it look i thought that the
idea of having bill macy direct me
and he is such a wonderful guy and i
loved him as a director he would sit and
play the ukulele
you know
he's a lovely man he's at being an actor
like he is the kind of actor he is he
knows exactly how to talk to actors he
knows exactly how to make it a fun time
and also there's a scent you don't take
it that i think it's it's for someone
like him it's like it's just fun and you
take it seriously but it's also you know
it's just a movie and i think sometimes
these movies can become like and you
have to remind yourself it's just a
movie there's no point in killing
ourselves over
um because i know he comes from that
david mamet school that is very much
like you just say the words say the word
say the words sure i think as a director
i mean he was he was a wonderful
director for performance obviously but
he also was very supportive and i think
that's a big part of
like i've took meisner and some of these
acting schools it can be quite abusive
and quite you know intense but i think
that there's a really important side of
of of training actors and directing
actors where you really have to nurture
them and make them feel secure and i
think confidence is such an important
part of a performance
totally do you feel yourself getting
more confident as an actor do you feel
yeah moments yeah every every year i
mean i'm a way better actress now than i
was
10 years ago 10 years before that
obviously and you know there's some
stuff i look back and i'm like okay but
you know i've gotten
uh
a lot better i have a clear
understanding of what i do i think i'll
only get better and hopefully and i
think a lot of that does come from
confidence and comes from
um it's cyclical you you know more than
you become more confident
is that were you do you always wanted to
do that when you were a kid that was
something that you grew up wanting to do
acting
yeah yeah yeah i i started acting when i
was 12 like 11 or 12
doing commercials and i just thought it
was quite do commercials and then the
kids at school would see me on tv and i
get to miss a day of school and and i
loved it did the kids think was cool or
did they
were you like ostracized at all for it
no i think i went to an all-girl private
school in new york some people were
indifferent
i wasn't like bullied or ostracized for
it yeah i mean i wasn't a cool girl i
had a group of friends a solid group of
friends but i wasn't like cool or
anything what was the cool click at that
school upper west side right like upper
east side yeah there was like the cool
girls
and i was definitely in
like a not that group for sure like i
didn't have boyfriends or kiss boys or
you know wear the cool clothes or and i
was like you know loud and talked a lot
and pretty nerdy
um wore my skirts too long and that kind
of thing were you into performing i mean
was it part of it like was there a drama
nerd element to that
yeah i was quite shy i had horrible
stage fright so i remember
you know but i did plays at school but i
um i was more just like like to do
characters and
would be loud and would the stage fright
go away when you were on stage would you
would it be something you had to man no
well not immediately but like it's the
same thing for me today i mean i've i
was very shy very nervous i had a bunch
of horrible screen tests and auditions
where i just would have full-blown panic
attacks in my teen years wow but yeah no
it's the same thing like you get
you get freaked out and nervous and then
once you get lost in it and then you
once you're done it's never that bad
this is another world i'm interested in
soap operas is that offensive to call it
soap operas no
okay
what should it be i don't know i mean i
just feel like that was what they
soap operas
that's what that's a whole genre i mean
that's
you know what you're what it is when you
say soap opera right okay like
nighttime soaps prime time that's
different but you know yeah and this was
a and this was something you did when
you were a kid right yeah so i got
started so i was
i you know
i was running around new york i was very
independent kind of on my own um like in
high school yeah in high school
you know it was weird it was like a
couple years after 9 11 and
my parents were working a ton and um
i booked this soap opera and i was at
this private school and i had to switch
schools to go because the school
wouldn't allow me to miss school like
that so i essentially at 16 made a
decision to really change the trajectory
of my life which i was probably on
already anyway so it was really lucky in
a lot of ways but i was so young and
naive and
and um
i wasn't a great actress and i was very
i didn't have any confidence i was
pretty scared and you know i think i had
kissed like two boys like i was very
same time
yeah
no i i think i was quite um i was quite
inexperienced in that department and
then all of a sudden you're on a soap
and they're putting you in little
outfits and you have to make out with
boys and
and
um not in a bad way i'm not saying it's
just
you know yeah yeah and it was all
thrilling but nerve-wracking and i
didn't know yeah i didn't really have
the tools to be a great actress and
um it was but it i learned how to hit my
mark and where lighting was and that
kind of thing life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
you said you weren't a great actress at
what point do you feel like that changed
and what why how did it change um i
think that
i had a lot of tools i had been to a lot
of class i think that i
between the
lessons i had taken over the years and
also just getting out there and doing it
learning from other actors gaining more
confidence
and i think for me i think confidence is
just such an important part of it and um
and losing inhibition like really just
not being afraid to try different things
and and just experience like if you do
things enough when you focus on enough
and you study enough
you'll get better but i always knew i
had a love for it and i always felt that
i could be good at it
and you know people may have differing
opinions on that and the kinds of movies
i do and whatever and but i have reached
a point where i really what i really
what it really is is that i really love
what i do and i
really care and i have really
i i feel really passionately about the
the
characters and i
um i i really do get lost
in them the majority of the time
was was there somebody alex who uh was a
like a mentor to you that took took you
under their wing with somebody that you
learned a lot from specifically yeah
there was a woman well there were a
couple teachers and then and i really
respect people acting coaches and people
like they care so much and they
even if they're you know sure you have
to dig deep and deal with some difficult
stuff and sometimes you have to get
really uncomfortable and that can feel
really strange but um
there was this one woman ann retrey
whose son i'm still really good friends
with devin retrey
and he's an actor he's a great actor
and his mother is this lovely
woman who she would have classes at her
apartment on the upper west side and i
remember
she would
give me all the positivity that i was
lacking because there was so much
you know
being thrown at me that was you know
you're not good enough and work harder
and be better and
you know that kind of thing and from the
soap world from
well
you know and it wasn't mean-spirited it
was true i mean and that's part of going
into a career in the arts and like you
know they're very direct they're great
if you're not going to get a [ __ ] job
if you you know right and so i
appreciate in a way that people were you
know
you're not working hard enough you're
not doing why aren't you telling the
truth right now don't you know you're
like why are you late you can't you
[ __ ] up your relationship with this
casting director because you were late
you know all that stuff that
irresponsibility that uh you needed that
maybe i needed it but i think it's it's
i wanted to be a better actress and so i
appreciated when even though it was hard
to hear i think especially looking back
i'm glad that people told me when i
wasn't doing well
and they're not fired from this they
hired me an acting coach who really
cared and really worked with me they
ended up firing me from the soap
and um i was devastated but it made me
want to be even better you know yeah
because that you because you had already
at that point in your life you had
already that was your path you you had
already determined
to do this so it's like you're now
getting fired you're getting you're in
trouble you're in some sort of
yeah
and no one's gonna do you any favors you
know but the one thing that was lacking
and it wasn't that people i really was
missing a very sort of
um
comforting maternal positive sort of
almost hippie vibe if that makes any
sense yeah totally yeah
was that she would like before a screen
test i remember she sat there and it was
a very safe environment where you could
really do no wrong but she tell you with
to do things again and you know that
kind of thing and how to fix them but
she'd white light you so she'd have the
whole class and everyone you'd sit in a
chair in the middle of the room and
they'd all like just close you close
your eyes and everyone sends you
positive white light
and
yeah and it was like i really i for some
reason needed that and she did that do
they make noises do they make sounds no
it wasn't like that
no it was just like
it was just
a very supportive positive like you're
going to get this job and you're amazing
wow and that combined with
you know you need to work harder you're
not good enough which is true it was
true yeah you were getting both yeah it
was a nice balance well i needed it you
know i didn't get fired because i was
the best soap actress in the world you
know what i mean yeah because if you if
you only had the retre
uh version right
it would be and i think a lot of people
especially now maybe have that because
uh there is the other side is like
potentially abusive and like
it's not necessarily
the only thing you want like i remember
my acting teacher in high school was
more that would like kind of put kids
down and was was not at all nurturing
and and
i think like you said i mean the the
most important thing is just developing
some sort of confidence especially when
you're that age yeah uh
how nice to have that yeah
yeah so she was she was she was a huge i
i credit her with a lot
but it's all you know it's everybody
it's it's all your experiences how is
kate i miss my buddy kate she's great
she's back in new york um
she is great
um
you know i think we're all just we're
all just wanting to get back to work and
but you know i feel like um
we went through this really difficult
experience together and i think that was
the hardest part for us and
um so we're we're it's probably closer
if that's why oh for sure
i think that was possible you guys were
like two peas in a pod yes yeah
yeah you're funny together because um
you're both very i just just being out
with you guys like i just seeing
people's reactions to you because you're
both you're you're like a good comedic
duo because you're
just your height differences
yes i don't know how to oh jesus
i don't know how to say that without um
no she's like half my size
yeah she's a little part she's a little
pint-sized so like if you look really
quickly you could potentially be the
mother in this situation but you guys
are like sassing each other and
yeah we sass each other we have great
banter yeah great banter you're funny
we're not you know lesbians we wish we
were because we would have a beautiful
partnership oh my god it'd be amazing i
know i think that with some of my
friends uh
we're not gay we get along we get along
we have all the stuff
figured out that would make a great
relationship you know what i mean we're
very very um
we're just very tight
yeah what what is the thing that you
[Music]
has been elusive when it comes to like
making a great relationship what is the
what is the the thing that kate has that
that is elusive in other people you
think you know i think that for me i
just haven't figured that part of my
life out um i think that um
you know i'm not 100 sure i've had some
really wonderful relationships that were
really i just think
it's easy to say oh i travel a lot and
that's complicated and it is i think
that is complicated but i think it's
just about finding someone that
um understands my lifestyle
and that is ready
for a relationship
and um you just have to find someone you
click with who
it's got to be right my goal isn't to
force it and i think uh
the thing about kate is that she as a
friend
she just
we just know how to communicate we
communicate really really well and we
have a ton of respect for each other and
we trust you can be honest we trust each
other
and i think that building trust
in any relationship romantic or
otherwise can be tough
and when you're traveling and you're not
always around and it's hard to sometimes
build that up
yeah it's and it's all that stuff the um
those unspoken moments even that even
having comfort
in silences uh
that's such a nice thing i've i've
noticed lately just being comfortable
sitting
in somebody's space and not feeling the
need to
you know fill it up it's a trust i guess
it's trusting yeah trust trust that they
you know are gonna take care of you and
that it's and it's like
it's like that you can sort of act you
know like family it's like that you can
sort of act however
and feel and go through whatever and
open yourself up and that you know that
um you can be vulnerable yeah be
vulnerable exactly yeah i think
vulnerability and i think vulnerability
is really hard for a lot of people could
we talk about john b
i met you through my friend john bess
who i think we've talked about on the
show um john is like a little comedic
powerhouse i would say he's like um when
i met him i felt like
whoever met adam sandler and chris
farley in the early 90s probably felt i
was like this guy is special i love john
bass he's so funny i haven't i haven't
seen him in forever and um i talked to
him briefly during quarantine but i
actually don't know what he's up to um i
need to get home with him but he's you
know he's john he's running around he's
busy he's running around i think he's
going
yeah but but just like an all-around
showman he's just such a good she's a
stage actor
he's so funny he's so talented yeah he's
a singer he's a book of mormon he's
funny he's dramatic he's um he's really
really he's he's awesome i love john and
you guys and you guys bonded uh doing
baywatch yeah we came super close on
baywatch um
and we ended up getting apartments in
the same sort of apartment complex and
uh
that was just like five minutes from set
and we would just hang out after work
savannah in savannah tybee island
and um it was nice to have you know
that kind of um
person to just at the end of the day go
and talk about you know the day
and that kind of how ridiculous because
there must have been a lot of like
ridiculousness on that there that's the
kind of movie where like you kind of
want to
sit with a friend over a drink and just
like
unpack what happened yeah but of course
and it was like you know when you're on
location you're away from
the people you're close to so it's
really cool when you get to forge that
kind of
friendship with your cast i was close to
the cast
did you watch that show as a kid were
you aware of the like
cultural phenomenon that it was sure
everyone knew what baywatch was but i
never watched it um
i i don't think i i think i missed i
don't know why it wasn't it just wasn't
one that i watched not for any
particular reason but i i of course i
knew exactly what it was i mean it's
baywatch it's it's like
yeah yeah
what did that feel like to work and
what's the rock like i don't think i've
ever asked you about the rock is he just
like everyone loves him yeah he's
exactly how he portrays himself okay
[ __ ] awesome dude
he's very straightforward i would say
he's really no [ __ ] but he has a
good sense of humor about himself
you know and um i i really liked working
with him do you call him dwayne
i call him dwayne yes
what do people say when they meet him
like he must have tons of people coming
up to him did they they call him rock
what do you well yeah he's the rock um i
think people do call him dwayne i mean
he has a big security team so i you know
but yeah i mean it's not like he's you
know
he's just one of those people i'm not
sure that he
gets out much you know what i mean
he's not mingling
he's so famous but he's also so just
like physically
you that guy would get he would attract
attention even if he weren't famous it'd
be like that guy's massive he's a r he's
the razor rack yeah he's like
um
yeah i remember walking around yeah with
with um
walking around
casinos in vegas with vince vaughn and
i think the only reason people would
stop as much as they would and notice
him was because he's so huge he's just
so
you know he's six foot five so it's that
people are already drawn to that yeah uh
he's a great guy i really like working
with him
um and honestly everyone on that cast on
baywatch was freaking awesome we had we
had a blast
true detective is something that people
probably first saw you in was that the
thing that kind of changed your career
it did i had a few blips like i had a
few things that changed my career
because it's just like a ladder i guess
i mean um yeah even the soap in a way
did because it got me
feeling more official and then uh percy
jackson which was like a big like
children's um
sort of action film oh yeah that's right
that's what got me out to la so i was 20
22 when i booked that and that's what
got me out to la so that was big and
then true detective really did change
things like from then on
almost from then on but it i've been
pretty much working consistently but
yeah it made a huge difference um and i
didn't expect it at all it came out of
nowhere because it was an arc it was a
couple episodes of a show you were
probably like oh i've been doing these
big movies yeah i was like i've been
doing these big movies and i'm still you
know
you know i was actually waiting tables
at one point after um
doing a couple of movies
yeah i ran out of time people were
probably wow where where was that alex
um oh god it was over on fairfax um
i forget what it was called now lalas
maybe
um but i uh
i
did true detective and i was like okay
well it's a great i love this director i
love these actors this is a different
pedigree than the type of stuff i've
been doing i think i have done like
texas chainsaw massacre and the person
jackson movies and and i was having
trouble getting in for certain things
auditioning wise and i just thought that
it would be a good thing to put on my
resume and a really good experience to
work with those kinds of people but did
i think that doing three four episodes
and getting naked was going to be
i it was risky
i didn't know that i didn't have a sense
of that everyone all of a sudden was
going to be like oh my god look at your
body i didn't i had been in a
relationship i i'd been with one man i
didn't have a sense of i was young i
didn't have any sense of the reaction
that was going to come from that and hey
i'm really grateful for it and i and the
show was such a phenomenon and
carrie's such an incredible director and
um so i feel really lucky well when you
were in high school you were saying like
you had never kid you had kissed like
two boys when you you're now
on a soap opera where you have to do
that kind of stuff it must have been
like a version of that where you're in
this you have one relationship you're in
this room and now you're seen in this
whole different
light yeah and i thought it was the
coolest thing ever in a way because i
had never considered myself sexy or
really thought i thought i was like a
goofy nerdy
theater kid who wanted to like be being
lame is and and
you know
boys never wanted to date me and i you
know i just was i never felt like a
super it wasn't that i wasn't confident
i was just very nerdy and goofy and uh
so
did
was that were you nervous then to do
something like that you described
anxiety about other
i was nervous to get naked yeah i was
quite nervous now i do that stuff more
often and i feel more confident
because the way that was received
because
you know you do it once
and it's like oh the world hasn't ended
i
i'm
you know this wasn't like uh
catastrophic this hasn't this has only
led to good yeah you know what it kind
of frees me up in a weird way especially
now i just feel like
it's
you know and i don't think that it's to
each their own and i
i i feel like part of being a feminist
and part of being a woman in hollywood
is
you know i'm
comfortable to the
degree that i'm comfortable i know
once your body's been out there
and it's kind of like
it is what it is like i i don't know how
else to explain it's not properly
articulated but i no no i think it's an
important part of building certain
characters and as as long as it's not
gratuitous i think that it can really
make an impact on the story
after that did you notice the difference
in the way guys treated you yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god it was like it was
it was relentless
and that took a little while to adjust
to because then i was the same person
but then the perception of it was
totally different so i'm like oh i'm
this goofy sweet girl and everything's
and i'm just a goofball and and then
it's like oh wait a second
you got a lot of growing up to do alex
you know and i got myself into a lot of
situations where i was like wow he
really seems to like me and it's like
no dude like yeah
lightning round okay what is your most
commonly used emoji probably
the heart emoji probably yeah
multi-purpose yeah uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play oh basketball
um and probably just because i saw the
michael jordan documentary and i got
really into it
oh my god how good it's so good
it's funny when you're a kid your
perception of somebody like that is
they're larger than life they're heroic
but it was amazing to see him like
humanized you know yeah i had no idea
about any of those aspects of his
personality at all no so it was it was
fascinating fascinating
and it makes total sense
of course yeah that he was so provoked
by
this competitive spirit just with like
other
teammates like players they could say
something to him and just make him just
be the best he could be i mean it's like
the opposite of how everyone else would
feel i mean it's so easy i mean as
actors
we're so sensitive if someone goes
you're a [ __ ] terrible actor you're
not gonna get this job you're like
you know you carry that into the room
but if someone says that to him he's
like he gets the [ __ ] job you know
like it's like the opposite of how most
people would react
yeah that's how he got space jam he was
in the waiting room for that every time
he lost he would win again the more i
was doing poorly at auditions the worse
they got you know what i mean
i know i know it's the polar opposite of
how i would react
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny at this point in my life
unattractive uh-huh
you know the thing that you value i like
that people think that i'm funny when
they think i'm funny you know yeah um
that they see that aspect of my
personality and i think sometimes people
don't see that
life could be a dream
hello hello again you're booming we'll
meet again
[Music]
you know who thinks you're funny is rob
hubel who i think is one i love rob
yeah yeah rob and i were oh that that
touches my heart
i remember before i met you rob had said
you would just because i did a show that
what is that show he did um
dead bodies
yeah and he was like uh
alex dadario just did this uh
she was real he went on about how funny
he was no way i mean that's that's
that's better than having him think i'm
attractive honestly i love that someone
like him thinks i'm funny i think that's
great
rob anytime you want me to do any other
show i'm down oh you know what you
should do he's been trying to get me to
do this and i have to do it uh
he does a show on instagram live about
ghost stories does he
yeah which you might have fun with um
uh i don't know if you have any
experiences with ghosts but uh if you do
if you know anyone who does if kate does
i have a couple ghost stories
oh please tell me your best one
um
god uh well there was one time i was
working on a set of i'll try to tell the
story quickly i was working on the set
of texas chainsaw massacre and we were
in some little town called i think
mansfield in louisiana
and um my stand-in i believe was a very
nice girl and i'd been working with her
for a couple weeks from the film school
there very normal person
um
young girl she she was all of a sudden i
believe crying and refusing to come to
set not in like but like very scared and
i wasn't really aware of what was going
on um but um
afterwards i was told we were shooting
in this house and afterwards i was told
that she saw a
uh a woman crying in the corner of the
room rocking back and forth saying why
are you all in my house while you're all
in my house and then she and she didn't
know she'd never been to mansfield she
didn't know anything about the house
i just got chills well it turned out we
found out afterwards because one of the
crew members apparently told the owner
of the house this and he goes oh yeah my
wife died in that room
and look i've never seen a ghost i've
never had a particular but i was like
this woman was so normal she was so hard
working and then for her to how on earth
would she have known right right do not
no one's i've
i've i've witnessed things like that or
people who have told
versions of that and
yeah you think that no one's a good that
good of an actor to to
to have that reaction no i don't think
he wasn't dramatically she had been very
like there was nothing that there was no
reason that she would have made that up
that just didn't go with her personality
wow
so wow
and did you have more to shoot in that
house did you have to be there longer i
think i found out about
that after
why she was crying after we had moved
out of the house i think we only shot
there a couple days
god oh i guess you could have used it
for the
yeah to be extra scared
yeah don't you hate when people i almost
just did i was like what am i doing i
almost asked you like did you ever get
scared when you were doing the horror
movie
people that's such a god that's not such
a common question
such a common question
it's like no
yeah it's like it's like
you know i got scared
that you know
i wasn't gonna be good yeah or i got
scared that you know production was
gonna kill me on some stunts because we
were yeah over rushing or whatever
but yeah
but
you know is there an actual stain on
that chainsaw today or are we you know
but like um
no i i think
but again it's like it's it's one of
those like disaster movie type things
where you have to work yourself up into
a complete frenzy
it's again i have such respect such
respect for
horror movie performances yeah um
i have to see yours i haven't seen it
but i've seen the remake of the
jessica uh that's a very good one
beer one very good yeah um
uh okay if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life oh wait sorry
what is your are you the knicks are you
a fan of the knicks i'm from new york so
yeah but aren't they i'm not that and i
actually don't watch a lot about i don't
watch a lot of sports yeah but aren't
they not doing well are they doing
better what's going on yeah yeah well
you're right about that
you know you
you know enough that they're not yeah
they're not
gonna be like oh the next thing uh you
know yeah
well you know you should um next time
you're in new york uh
we got to go to a game because the one
indulge one of the like those
indulgences where like
you know they've grown a virus
there's no audiences yet are there no
it's weird no if you want if you watch
the playoff show on now and if you watch
they have like fake heads they have like
digital heads yeah i saw that that guy
soccer game it's like
i can't imagine playing
for you know or is it easier or is it
like we were talking about with acting
is it less pressure is it like just your
teammates encouraging you and not having
like 60 000 people being like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] suck you do theater and film
i mean theater's kind of cool because
it's a living breathing thing you get
that reaction immediately that's true
that is true
um
but it's weird i'm also very sensitive
to
the audience so if somebody in the
audience as i am i'm one of those
annoying people on
movie sets where if it's like
i'm very embarrassed to admit this but
if somebody's in my eye line or doing a
thing in my eye line i'm not like i'm
not a dick about it i try to be
respectful i'm like i'm so sorry can you
move out of that
but i'm very easily distracted by
anything that ruins the illusion that
we're just
talking right and there's there aren't
cameras around you know i tried do
people pull their phones out in
audiences a lot and do you notice it
so i was gonna say once i was doing a
play a couple years ago in san diego and
a guy
and we all did because and i do a lot of
talking to the audience in this play is
steve martin play um
picasso little panthers
yeah oh so fun um and i'm playing
einstein so i'm doing these things to
the audience i'm talking to them and
there's a guy in the for the first
couple of scenes who i s in the front
row
who was on his thing texting
um uh you could see the little glow of
the
and it was so
i i i we were all so enraged and
you know
i think if i'd been more experienced
with that i would have just
stopped it and said something
or that i mean that's like the patty
lupone thing yeah
put your phones down have you seen that
yeah like shaming the audience i don't
blame them it's two hours for you to sit
there you paid to go it's like
living theater everything's digital now
everything's you know it's like this is
it's a unique experience we don't even
get to have it now for two years i know
this horrible
thing and it's like i know
i know you know the first thing that's
gonna happen when theater comes back is
the
people are going to be right there on
their phones again like they can't help
well
well as it turns out this guy was pissed
about
his i guess there was a seat next to him
i remember empty seat and i guess his
wife hadn't been allowed in because she
was just late in the theater they're
very strict about rules like that if you
get there after the curtain goes up it's
like sorry you gotta like wait till the
next scene so she he was pissed and so
he was like defiantly which is like it's
not the actor's fault i don't know that
that
it was a very wealthy audience and
there's some entitlement again
everything's emotional so it's he got
caught up in an emotion
he wasn't thinking dario theory
you're right by the way that's a perfect
illustration of your theory
he just wasn't thinking he
you know feeling of anger and
frustration
right he's not thinking about the
actress didn't cause this i'm angry
right i'm just
expressing it right um
i like that uh
what is your favorite oh what's the if
you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be um
popcorn
i'm a big popcorn fan anything on it any
uh no i like like butter on it or olive
oil
i mean sort of boring yeah i like like i
like like good unhealthy popcorn
what's your favorite movie of all time
or or alex i should say in in quarantine
what is the movie that like has kind of
like the way the jerk did for me last
night that has brought you a lot of
comfort
oh god what have i been watching in
quarantine i mean mainly reality tv has
brought me comfort um
uh
i really well this is a show i started
watching dead to me
and i was totally comforted by that show
i i you know i'm not exactly sure why
maybe because it
i think it was sort of cathartic to
watch people in a comedic setting that
were going through some i don't know how
exactly to explain it i loved that show
i really loved that okay that's
christina applegate um christina
applegate yeah
um and uh oh god cardellini uh linda
carter oh linda cardinality yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's fantastic bloodline i
loved her um
okay uh if you had to live somewhere
else where would it be
new orleans
uh yeah um which is kind of a weird
answer
yeah well i mean
i just love new orleans
um i would love to live in in europe too
somewhere in europe i just don't i'd
have to go somewhere english speaking
somewhere in scotland
do you do you have a go-to restaurant in
new orleans where like you're there for
two or three days and you have you you'd
be pissed at yourself for not going to
this
coast john
have you been i'm obsessed oh yeah i am
obsessed
i used to go there by myself and order
some moonshine and like pork cheeks and
like the aloe fried alligator and just
like oh it was a like such a nice treat
i love it there that sounds
so good i'm so mad we can't be there
right now um
okay if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met uh who would who would they be this
is a tough lightning round i hate these
questions because they're going to have
better answers that i'm going to get no
no but you know you know three people
living your debt i mean steve martin
would have to be on there and you know
what
yeah steve martin
um
i mean bill gates i would be really
interested in speaking to although he's
you know and um
i mean i should pick all dead people why
am i picking people um i it shouldn't be
this hard
no it is hard to pick a woman too that's
what's going through my head
yeah so far too and two white guys
i'd love to i'd love to
that's great
oh god
i would really be curious just politics
like you know i'd be really curious
politics wise to like sit with like
trump
uh merkel yeah
angler and like
throw justin trudeau in there like she's
a friend of mine oh yeah okay yeah oh
yeah
but like that would be an entertaining
dinner like if i just if i'm just
looking for entertainment right now
which you know i am pretty bored so why
not it's like yeah let's throw justin
trudeau trump and her together and just
see what happens i just would need
everyone to be very very honest though i
don't want anyone putting on any sort of
politeness
see a lot of people say when they answer
that they're like yeah i i i have a
feeling that if you're
um
with people like that they're not going
to necessarily want to talk about
what they do for liver well it's like
you had a dinner like you go on you go
to dinner with somebody like you don't
want to talk about acting even though
we've been talking about acting the
whole time
you don't know like just like talk about
your career or at you know uh so i
wonder if that would apply to like
trudeau and trump and well they'd have
to i mean is this my fantasy or is this
like that's true you'd have to it's your
fantasy you're right this is not a real
world situation i'd ask some questions
i'd be like so justin how do you really
feel
tell us how you really feel
that's good remember when they they
accidentally some reporter accidentally
recorded some real reaction of
politicians at some big event back in
february and everyone was like losing it
was so refreshing to see like
the queen might be like to her sister
like you say hello right now you know
like like these are the most powerful
people in the world and they're like and
they're like i gotta take a [ __ ]
and she's like i don't like trump and
it's like too bad you say hello to him
we have to be nice to our our neighbors
over here you know it's so funny
i love seeing those human moments with
people who are like quote unquote larger
than life and i love being reminded that
like everyone shits
and everyone yeah exactly
human beings
yeah
um
except speaking of
uh who's your favorite muppet
speaking of
my friends
i'm gonna confuse the muppets and the
other ones um i mean kermit the frog's a
muppet
yeah miss piggy i mean those are my
favorites
okay i think i don't know why you're so
defensive
i just feel like i don't have a good
answer for it so that's a great answer i
got emotional because
yeah okay all right that's the tutorial
theory strikes again
um
i've asked you this i know but i see
signs all the time on my right up from
where i'm now to massachusetts
you have nothing to do with d'addario
the the
auto company the connecticut dealership
so
i don't have anything to do with the
d'addario strings guitar strings for
people who play guitar
there's sometimes i get that question
but my family my father's family is from
connecticut and there was some big i
believe construction company
daddario and that was my grandfather's
brother and it was some big
we don't we're not part of it but it is
part of our sort of close family i don't
know the auto or what that is but i that
there's a lot of my close relatives in
connecticut so my assumption is this
was this the grand the congress
or the brother of the congress um
and alex is he still alive he is not no
um he passed away no no i mean he was in
his 90s when he passed away
but yeah he was a very interesting guy
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life physically what what would you
pick i mean i think 28 is a good one 28
it's great
i'm very content with where i am right
now i i'm actually not
you know i'm i'm totally fine being 34.
uh yeah i'm very content with how i look
and the whole thing but i think 28 your
health your healthiest right i could
yeah i could run faster i could totally
drink more like yeah well yeah
now it's like i have two glasses of wine
and it's like oh my god forget it
oh wait don't you hit 40.
um
yeah if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick i
guess a dog i mean one that was well
taken care of
yeah a levon a levon type dog yeah
is a little bit like [ __ ] levon has
a [ __ ] he does the jerk i've heard
that before he does look a little like
[ __ ] it's one of my prouder it's one
of my sources of pride with my dogs that
he looks like [ __ ]
if you haven't seen the jerk that
probably sounds like a strange uh the
dog and the jerk
yeah um
god that movie is good um okay
which do you do you know the golden
girls um have you ever watched the
golden girls yeah which one do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia i'm like a combo i mean yeah
that's okay dorothy was
the i'm a combo of dorothy was like the
really
uh played by oh my god
yeah dorothy was she was like really
strict and always like angry at
everything she was the pragmatic one
i'm a combo of that and rose is is uh
uh what's her name betty white betty
combo of the two of them ah that's a
good combination
uh yeah i think so there's because rose
has uh
she has a baddie but really like fun
good time quality
i would like to go to
uh coach with with rose and yeah like
i'm a little i'm a little like naive and
childish and like a little like eyes
wide open oh this is so exciting and
then i'm a little bit like saying olaf
and then i can be very like no we're not
doing that and i don't know yes
interesting and who would kate be like
when you're with kate who who what would
your golden girl dynamic be um
i don't think she's any of them she's so
sensible about everything she's very
like kate's a very
um
she's just very she's
very emotionally in tune she's very kind
and she's very sensible but she's goofy
she's quite goofy she's she's got a
little bit of rose yeah she's getting
some sophia i can see a little like
what'd you say yeah um uh okay dogs are
cats do you prefer dogs
everyone's allergic to cats oh you are
no not me but everyone seems to be so if
you have one in your house no one can
come into your house
right right so if you're like reclusive
and you want people to stay away it's a
nice probably pet
um beetles are the rolling stones the
beatles
okay do you have a favorite song by the
beatles i mean blackbird um
happiness is a warm gun uh yeah
yeah i like the beatles and i like the
rolling stones but the problem was i was
a bartender and the owner of the bar
would obsessively play rolling stones
really loud every single day and i
associate i started to associate the
rolling stones with that horrible job
and being up until six in the morning
and so i have like a negative
association with with stone songs uh
what where was is this in l.a
in new york back in
2004 to 2008.
um yeah pop and burger they were called
wow that's amazing it's while you were
on a soap off i think people probably
think like oh you're on a soap opera
you've made it you no it was afterwards
so i was fired from the soap in 2003
and then i graduated high school i was
16 when i was on a soap and then i was
18 and then i started working at the bar
and um right after i think i hadn't even
graduated yet when i started working
there
wow got that smell of old beer no yeah
i'll never forget cleaning the bar at
the end of the night
yeah yeah um
how do you ever think about how you want
to be remembered like if is is legacy
something that you think about alex um
i try to always aspire to be a better
person and i really i just want to be
kind person and i don't
put any expectations on any of that but
i i
hope that i'm remembered for you know i
love my friends and i try my best and i
hope that people love me when i go you
know less so than like some grand legacy
but i really cared about what i do all
that kind of stuff i i'm ambitious and
all that and i would love to have more
success than i have but i'm also very
content with what i have and um i would
love to more so be remembered for you
know
being a good person
yeah being loved yeah being like having
you know i just i i have such great
people in my life and i i'm really
grateful that i have such a wonderful
group of people around me
well i'm grateful to be on the outskirts
of that group i'm it's so nice
thanks for doing i know this is like i
always feel a little guilty especially
no i'm so glad you get to i get to talk
about myself for an hour and a half how
wonderful
well you're great at it oh thank you
uh no this was fun thanks pal i
appreciate it thank you i'll talk to you
soon
[Music]
well well that's just how that happened
uh that happened uh we're gonna do like
half
so that happened
it's that's too like pompous or chill
well
well that happened well that happened
hmm
i can't picture his voice i can't hear
this it's very i i just know that he's
very uh he has an authoritative he's
very theatrical yes yes yeah i'm
picturing now that i like the show i
like the show
it's so good we gotta i gotta re-watch
that anyway did you like the interview
did you like the interview i liked it
she reminds me of emmy rossum a bit
she's got this like
patent sophisticated
similar background self-assured yes kind
of deliberate they have similar
backgrounds yes yeah interesting you're
right yeah kind of a uh yes a type a yes
well said she's um
she's like i could picture her as a boss
yeah you know a boss bish you're not
supposed to say that bish yeah but boss
shouldn't like boss bish should just be
just a boss regardless of her gender
yeah justin i'm sorry
sorry
uh you're right you're right sorry
she does have boss energy boss i think
you say boss bish i said boss bish oh
really yeah your chest
you had banished me
uh she's boss she's like a boss lady
that's bad too boss lady
what's what do you say boss boss gender
neutral yep boss she's a boss [ __ ] i
thought it was funny can a man be a
[ __ ] uh you've called me a [ __ ] before
you oh you you've been a [ __ ]
isn't bish good and [ __ ] is bad i don't
know i'm out of touch
you're asking the wrong person i'm
asking the wrong [ __ ]
what's the one i like now um oh [ __ ] i
mean we've been talking about wow
can we say that we can say wow we can
say the acronym we can't say what it
stands for well it's also we're not
saying [ __ ] like uh the derogatory
term it used to be no no no for like
that's three months no not [ __ ] right
which was was stood for without papers
which was derogatory for italian
americans um
we're saying wap which stands for what
does that stand for justin
that's all i can say okay
but everyone can fill in the rest
but yes very popular song cardi b
hopefully future guests uh i thought it
was funny when you told her she had a
sinister face
and then you like immediately backfilled
you're like i mean obviously i'm so
pretty yeah that's a tough it's tough to
like um
because i d it's weird you don't want to
sound
uh i didn't want to sound like i was
objectifying her in a even in a good way
like i didn't want to sound at all
it's just a strange position to be in
but but there is a
an aesthetic reality about somebody like
alex i agree with you yeah yeah by the
way i do think she can look sinister
yeah and i am pretty i'm pretty but like
it's it i meant it more as a testament
to
uh her the casting of her and her
performance right yeah i i know you man
i'm not her eyes though it's i just
thought it was funny that you had the
balls to say it to her i agreed well i
didn't have the balls to commit to it no
but she also didn't have the balls to
commit to saying she's pretty yeah
that's true she like almost said it and
then she was like
i mean i don't know what people think of
me whatever they've been yeah i mean
we've talked about how that's hard to do
it's hard to do but it's also not that i
know from experience
trust me
uh but we've we've had guests on the
show that we have lauded for their
ability to do that you know all right
uh you talked about john bass at one
point and he
is very funny but do you remember when
when i we saw him last i was when i saw
him last at williamstown no i see i had
met him at williamstown i had this whole
long night with him a great conversation
for hours i sat next to him we were all
having drinks outside and i thought we
really connected and i thought we like
really hit it off and granted this was
like nine ten years ago now
and we saw the city then no no so then i
didn't see him for years after that for
like six seven years eight years after
that and i
i saw him and i was like hey and i like
went up to give him this big hug and he
had to sort of like limp arms at his
side
and i pulled back and i realized he had
absolutely no idea who i was
like it didn't even
it didn't even ring the bell
that's the worst it was so sad and i was
like how did i have ah yeah he made such
an impression on you such an impression
on me and and i made a zero impression
on him and i thought i made a good
impression on that yeah well wow it was
six seven years ago yeah and i was so
then i had to pivot and say oh we met
yeah years ago and he was like oh really
even that's in jog's memory oh man he
was like oh it's good to see you again
but don't you think like i mean this
isn't a great consolation but because
you've seen he's been since you met him
he then started appearing in a lot of
things right so i've seen him a lot yeah
so you are more familiar with him and
also maybe not a constellation but he's
lived a much more
exciting life i would say that i have
over the last 10 years we should actu
this is ironic that we were so i've so i
get lowered in his memory bank of you
know things to hold on to yeah he worked
with the rock and not to be like
faux modest or anything but
a knight talking to me is not as
exciting as
five months for the rock and alex
baywatch with alex catario and the rock
sorry uh i like how much she likes new
orleans and cochon the restaurant yeah
martin i know she's got some really cool
interests good taste yeah i i thought
you'd like that cochon because that's uh
chris do i say that that we love cochon
and yeah
yes this sounds really bougie i love new
orleans um i know and if and if you god
i don't think i've ever heard you say
boujee before well maybe because the
boucherie sounds a lot like it and it's
i think it applies but i don't think
i've heard you say that word uh
really yeah i don't think so boujee i
don't say it a lot who says that a lot
boujee i hear it a lot from people i
don't hear you say it though
anyway
uh she
i like how um
seriously she took the lightning round
because she really cared about giving
good answers and i think that's part of
the
kind of like type a like i want to
present the best version of myself
personality trait yeah and she would
kind of search for things be like oh
that's not a good answer if i had more
time to think about i want it like she
wanted to improv
not just impressed but she wanted to
give the best version of her yes yeah
yeah that that's what i'm which i think
is um
i think that's an attractive quality
wanting to be yeah yeah she cares about
it put her best foot forward yeah just
the fact that she was she cared about it
yeah yeah that's nice but i at the same
time i like when people like carrie
brownstein kind of give it no thought
and just like whatever comes in their
head yeah this is the most
honest like spur of the moment right but
i also appreciate someone who a little
thought
yeah you know give good answers yeah i
appreciate that and i thought for sure
she would just be a dorothy but
the rose dorothy hybrid i've never
thought of i know a lot of people are
hybrids you're obviously
uh a rose
uh blanche hybrid
and i'm i think obviously a dorothy
sophia
more dorothy i've never thought of the
dorothy rose because they seem so
different from each other they too i can
see her though having a little bit of
rose i
and and a little sophia i can see her
having like kind of like she's
mischievous yeah a little she if you
ever watch her instagram bits that she
does with kate and her friends uh
there's a lot of there's there's sophia
in that she gets really like she likes
to like she's a little like mischief
yeah yeah rascal
okay letter okay
this is from stew
stew by the way spelled s-t-u
stew cool subject cool right yeah i i
like that yes stu it's a cool name it's
like yeah just a straight shirt straight
yeah
yeah you both have to think the name
stupid belies a straight shooter the
lies
subject uh greetings from cali colombia
and expat themed would you rather wow
they had a couple expat letters
[Laughter]
justin and christian in parentheses and
maggie oh
i'm an american currently living in cali
oh oh i'm sorry cali columbia i'm an
idiot
i thought it was two different places
cali comma columbia i'm an american
currently living in maybe it's
pronounced kali kali colombia cali and
your podcast was one of the best things
i discovered during the strict
five-month lockdown that we just got out
of on september 1st so thanks wow
jeez
i've been here almost two years so i'm
not one of those who is trapped here due
to the borders being closed i work
online and with being forced to stay
home
with no place else to work like coffee
shops or co-working spaces you guys
really helped me pass the time oh thanks
dude
that's awesome one of my favorite
episodes wasn't it thanks dude
thanks
thanks thanks dude thanks stu thanks
dude
it's like uh it's like hugh like
thanking a guy named hugh
oh thanks you
uh one of my favorite episodes was mira
sorvino where i learned that just
because she was tarantino's girlfriend
at the time and refused weinstein's
advances was all she had to do to get
black blackballed from hollywood for a
while despite being an oscar winner i
thought that was fascinating and a
little sad
yeah it's both both yeah
i have a couple columbian slash expat
themed would you rather's oh cool would
you rather
number one spend five months in
quarantine in a foreign country alone
where you don't know the language
meaning every interaction of going to
the bank or the market or other
essential needs means you are having to
try to communicate in this foreign
language
or wow god that must be tough or spend
five months at home but stuck with the
three people you most dislike in the
whole world
oh and google translate sucks for the
local language wow when you're home
are you allowed to leave your
home i think five months stuck like
quarantined in the house like
colombian-style lockdown in the house
board of the house and i was born
three people you most dislike in the
whole world i'm trying to think who that
would be even so you can't learn the
language you can't even get better at it
can you like don't know the language
only every interaction of going to the
bank uh let's assume you can't and you
just have to use like broken english to
but how would you get anything done i
mean you'd be uh you you'd have to mime
he suggests that google translates sucks
so this is so the implication being that
you can at least try okay
um you know what i i i would try i would
try in the foreign language in the
future um because i would like to do an
immersion anyway i've been trying as you
know trying to do duolingo
christian hates it but um
i i think that's exactly what i would
need to like take it to the next level
yeah that's a good reason to do it and
also there's something nice sounding
about
uh being on your own yeah it's if it was
a year it's a different story five
months five months
it's a long time but it's a long time
but it's it would be an interesting
experience it'd be an adventure on your
own yeah yeah i would do that all right
is there another one number two
get a lifetime of colombian coffee fresh
delivered to you and in return
you have to give up all other drinks
besides water or
never ever have coffee or tea ever again
but you can drink as much of whatever
else you want oh wow i i love coffee but
um i would give up coffee yeah there's
just too many other drinks i like i know
what what what's the first thing you
think of like it would be hard to not
have that ever again i can't believe i'm
saying this but it's a smoothie oh
a green i drink uh like a green oh yeah
i'm drinking it right now every morning
yeah and it i think it's important for
my health
i would really miss that me too my body
would miss that it's become such a
staple in my life on the other hand i
would also miss martinis yeah yeah i
would you know i would miss some this is
i wouldn't miss like seltzer of course
i'd miss uh
taro bubble tea oh i'd miss that i
missed milkshakes you both have to miss
milkshakes in this hypothetical
drink yeah i love coffee and i like tea
but i i would definitely have to get rid
of it i would get used to i'd have to
have a different stimulant in the
morning i'd have to like
do blow in the morning to get my day
started
grab like a monster
yeah gross um i know just put all those
chemicals into your body i've gotten
used to that morning stimulant i know
routine it would be tough to
to get over that i know you know i was
always so proud of myself for not
because i stopped drinking christian i
both had worked at a coffee shop uh no
longer there sad cafetaza uh in
fairfield and i drank so much coffee
that
i don't remember why i think once i went
to college and i
i had other vices i um i felt like oh
that's something i can give up i didn't
need to
drink it so i just stopped for like up
until i did a play when i was like 38
maybe so for a good 12 15 years of my
life and i was always like so proud of
it
you know and so i know i can do it
uh-huh
but i and i would always like kind of
judge people who were like oh i'm not
i'm not myself until i get that coffee
and now i've become that person well
there's also i think we're at a certain
age where things become more kind of
slow and boring to the point where i
really look forward to having coffee in
the morning and doing a crossfit puzzle
like i really love that combination
and the thought of not being able to do
that is kind of sad to me but it also
not be able to there's so many more
things i know
i'd rather so i'd give up the coffee
uh good one uh and there's another one
there's a couple more well uh number
three live in any non-new york city city
without a car and be able to spend an
average uber rate of only three dollars
per ride but you can't go more than 50
miles outside the city ever or
live in a very small town in the middle
of nowhere five hours from the nearest
city but you can drive wherever you want
i would live in the middle of nowhere
wow i love how specific it is
but yeah i mean can you have friends in
your little town nowhere yeah yeah i'm
sure it'd be annoying for them if it's
like the shining then i would rather
live in say
uh boston and just walk a lot that's
true
yeah boston's okay so in this
hypothetical
if
if i had new orleans new orleans take
that if i had neighbors or a lover or a
brother or uh
even like someone i was casually
acquainted with who lived down the
street and anything like that i would
definitely pick the town but if i was
all by myself
i would i would live in a city that was
good for walking like uh
well not portland but boston
new orleans new orleans you know both if
you want to know the
would come visit sure uh yeah see i i
mean
in massachusetts i'm about two and a
half hours three hours outside the city
five hours is a lot that's people don't
want to come this visit yeah five hours
is no joke five hours is the closest
that'd be tough i'd live in a i'd live
in uh i think i would live in maybe
maybe more austin i prefer town i prefer
suburb to uh urban environments in
general but in this hypothetical i think
i'd have to do i might live in new
orleans new orleans city yeah or
vancouver is great all right uh which
then you can never let that sorry yeah
and then you can never leave though you
can't you can never go more than 50
miles past it so but see new orleans is
cool like such different parts 20 miles
past it you're like in the bottom i know
yeah i know you really feel like you're
in the middle of nowhere yeah that'd be
a cool thing to do yeah there's such
different parts of that city what a
beautiful god i miss that um okay
the next hypothetical is which great
sandwich would you rather do without
uh philly cheesesteak or ruben and i
know your answer
but i just thought of that great
sandwich place in new orleans um
uh not bay cities that's la uh parkway
parkway uh great po boys oh my god so
it's what sandwich would you rather do
without yeah philly cheesesteak or ruben
neither of which are available here in
colombia although i can get a decent
steak sandwich it sounds like he's
really missing
the u.s doesn't it yeah well i would say
i really like a good philly cheesesteak
but my favorite sandwich of all time is
reuben yeah so i would rather
do without the stick you made that easy
for him stu i would i would take the uh
do without the reuben because
i prefer philly cheesesteaks uh and
lastly since you guys live or have lived
on both coasts would you rather live
with the same weather all the time but
it's uncomfortably cooler than you would
prefer
every day
or
have four seasons this is easy for me
four seasons yeah
i love the four seasons yeah in fact
right now it's like as much as i enjoy
the summer it's beautiful
i'm really looking forward to the fall
you know what's funny i love the leaves
changing that's the crisp
material both have to love chris bear i
got excited
when because it's been it just started
turning a little bit
and it's it's exciting that's my
favorite time of year i've also noticed
that i've been
i just said this to a friend who was
like how is it out there are you are you
going stir crazy you know everyone i'm
sure you listening have all texted
your friends similar things like um and
i found myself uh
and this is a very privileged thing to
be able to uh realize but i found myself
being
much more connected to the weather
nature and be more present to that you
know uh so yeah that that crispness is
like extra exciting this year for some
reason yeah um and it's funny he says
four seasons because uh i'm now i think
about my time in london
i saw a great concert uh vivaldi's where
they did vivaldi's four seasons i just
watched by myself who's [ __ ] i smoked
a little we it was so enjoyable
at a church anyway
great time miss london miss traveling
keep up i'd love to go to columbia one
day maybe stu can
give me cali columbia i gotta check that
out keep up the great work says stu and
he signs his name thanks to thank you
stu whatever good would you rather yeah
very specific you know both other like
the would you rather
um and congratulations on having a very
cool name yeah yeah
thank you stu and thank you to the
another cool name very intelligent
charming yep alexander d'addario
d'addario and our guest thank you to
everyone listening yes this is a really
fun if you want to write in and be the
next stu even if you don't have as cool
of a name as him that's okay
our email address is life is short at
wandery.com
i don't know why i said that in such a
mysterious way but i don't either.com
that's what that's what you're feeling
all right impish maybe maybe that's a
little bit of uh sophia in you coming
out little d'addario a little vimpish oh
i can only hope um
we will check in with you next week stay
safe life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's i don't know why i'm so down
about that it's produced by you and
co-hosted by you christian as well as uh
produced by megan monaco senior
producers michelle miesh lambs executive
producers audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producers are ernan
lopez and marshall louie i reverse those
yeah what
i'm evolving
[Music]
so so watching uh
watching footage split up between donald
trump at wrestling events and the rock
at wrestling events
and mom said
wait a minute wait a minute he really
did that he really in this whole time
christian i've been like yeah they
actually filmed trump doing a thing once
and like and then at the end we
discovered that no no the rock
she was more surprised by the rock
having been a wrestler
you